Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about MetaHumans.
What are those? Well, see here for yourself.
This will be a culmination of a ton of
papers that we talk about here. For instance,
the hair has to be simulated, often strand by
strand. The appearance of skin has to be correct,
and deformations to the skin also have to
be simulated correctly. And here comes the
most challenging part: all this on
a shoestring computational budget,
or in other words, yes, in real time. Is
this even possible? Well, let’s see together!
Yes, this is Metahuman, part of Unreal Engine
5, a popular game development platform where
we can create virtual humans like we would do in
a video game, with the difference that these are
incredibly high quality models. Today, millions
of these Metahumans already exist. But that is
nothing compared to what you are about to see
now. Now they have introduced Metahuman Animator,
where we can scan ourselves, and enter a virtual
world. So they say, so let’s have a look together!
First, we capture ourselves, and by that I
mean our appearance and gestures too. Then,
after less than a minute of processing, now it
is able to locate and track facial landmarks,
like the eyes, eyebrows and mouth, and now, it
can show us the DNA of our virtual character.
This can mimic our gestures really well already.
But I hear you saying, okay Doc, but it doesn’t
look like a test subject at all. So now, hold on
to your papers Fellow Scholars, and watch this.
Wow, now we’re talking! That is simply
incredible. This did not require the
expertise or a group of artists, a huge studio
with a huge budget, and it did not even require
months of work. It is done right as we’re
talking in minutes. What a time to be alive!
And if that is at all possible, it gets even
better! We can also transfer these gestures
to a variety of different characters.
That is excellent in and of itself,
but just imagine how we could make
completely virtual characters and
life forms come to life with our
own gestures. How cool is that?
And here are a few more features that
I absolutely loved. We can design the
full body of our characters, we
can even choose clothes for them,
and if we are not happy with our character,
we can even make small adjustments to it.
Now, after creating or scanning these characters,
they are now allowed to enter a virtual world.
However, when they move around in this
world, their movement and as a result,
deformations of their muscles have have to
be simulated. This can be done with a coarse
simulator that runs in real time, however,
those are not nearly as good as these ones.
Now these are absolutely amazing. However,
these simulations take forever. And I really
mean forever - these simulations are measured not
in frames per second, but in seconds per frame,
and it gets even worse, sometimes even minutes
per frame. This is the price to be paid for these
super accurate simulations. Until now. You see,
these simulations can also be done super quickly
with learning-based methods, and now, these also
run in real time. Just look at how realistic this
movement is. And this will run on our computers,
and later, even on our phones. And get this,
this also applies for garment simulations as
well. I have highlighted the relevant regions
where the new, neural network-based technique
generates these really cool folds on the cloth.
Wow. As you see, we are living incredible
times, and this will put gaming,
animation movies, virtual worlds, perhaps
even conference calls to the next level.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!